With that very humbling introduction,
kind of rounding applause
from Robbie Brown. Wow.
I like to meet that guy. He sounds
really impressive. Uh, thank you. Uh,
first of all, uh, thanks to Google
for hosting all of us here today, um,
and the campus that you're building here
in boulders is beautiful and we're all
very happy to have you in our
city and, and in our state. Um,
as I said,
my name is Bobby Brown and I'm the
dean of the College of Engineering and
Applied Science at the University
of Colorado Boulder. Uh,
we are among the fastest
growing engineering colleges
and we're actually one of
the most diverse colleges of
engineering in the country.
And that's something that
we're really proud about, uh,
because it allows us to reach out and
partner more with industry in our state
and including, uh, Google.
Uh, I'm a Mars Guy, um,
uh, I guess, uh, maybe a Martian, uh, in,
in my blood and I've
worked on a number of, uh,
NASA missions and typically I work with
engineers and scientists on what it's
like to build and send spacecraft to Mars.
Uh,
but today I'm here with a really
interesting group of people,
uh, people who I've had the
pleasure to work with, uh,
for a number of years now, uh, in, uh,
what's been a groundbreaking a television
series put on by National Geographic
with executive producers, Ron
Howard and Brian Grazer. Uh,
and, uh, I got to tell you,
working with these people,
it's been like, like a family.
Uh, and for me as an engineer, uh,
perhaps the best thing
has been working with a,
not with other engineers but
with artists and, uh, you know,
a film studies folks,
actors,
writers and big thinkers,
uh,
from across the spectrum,
that had been part of this
innovative docu drama.
How many of you have seen any of the
episodes a season one or season two?
Yeah, that's a good number.
That's a good number.
It's season two's going on right now.
Uh, we just, uh, just last night,
episode four, uh, was
premiered on Nat Geo.
Uh, they're showing a
Monday nights, 9:00 PM.
You can catch up with
those and you can, uh, uh,
actually see episode five and six have
yet to come out tonight on our campus at
cu boulder. Uh, we'll be
premiering a episode five.
You can see it on campus a week before a,
it'll actually be shown worldwide. Uh,
so that's what we're all here today.
We're here for this event. Uh, and then
for this evening's event in boulder.
Uh,
I'm here today,
joined with a number of the
members of the show, uh,
in various capacities, uh,
going, uh, from my, uh,
going down this way. I
always, I always mess that up.
My left, but it's there, right?
Let's do it that way. Uh,
the first new corrects me the most in
my life is actually Steven Channick who,
uh, you know, over the years
has been a great friend. Uh,
Steven is a co executive producer
of the series, and in fact,
the series is based on a book,
uh,
that Steven wrote years ago about how
we will actually live and settle the
planet Mars.
Uh,
he's really the creative
genius behind the whole series,
if you will, uh, through his book.
And it's wonderful to have you here in
boulder today. Uh, next to him is Antonia.
You Haas,
uh,
who is an expert in oil and energy policy,
and has written numerous papers and,
and given numerous forums on those topics,
uh, in this series. Uh,
she's a big thinker.
So this is a series,
right?
That goes back and forth between the
present and the future, right? So you,
we talk about what's happening in our
world today and then we flash forward from
that into how that might might portray
into a human settlement of Mars in the
future.
And Antonio has been wonderful
in providing insights
about climate and energy,
uh, and policy, international
policy issues here on the
earth and how those might,
those same kind of issues
might play out on March.
And then next to her is actually
an award winning writer, uh,
Leonard David, uh, who, if you're
in the space community like I am,
Leonard needs a no introductions.
Uh,
but Leonard has written a book that
is a companion book to the National
Geographic series. If you're
interested, you can pick one
up, uh, on the back table,
uh, there, uh, but Leonard's book, uh, is,
is a great companion to the series,
provides wonderful context about past,
present, and future Mars exploration. Uh,
and so we're here today. Uh,
what we're going to do is
we're going to, uh, watch, uh,
the trailer from season one just to
bring you up to speed about what happened
two years ago during
season one, uh, which,
which took place in the 2030s a.
Then we're going to show the trailer
for season two. Uh, but before I do,
there's two other folks I definitely
want to introduce very quickly, uh,
in the audience who will be
speaking tonight on campus.
Uh, and there are actors,
uh, in the Nat Geo series and
that Sammy road TV, maybe Sam,
you want to stand up?
Oh,
and Evan Hall.
And as someone
who's, uh, consulted, uh,
on the show and worked with some of the
writers and actors in the production of
the show, you know, they've
been fantastic. Uh, you
know, the, the, these guys,
it just,
their roles are so,
it's amazing how well they
suited into these roles.
I know that you each have an
engineering background and you know,
you have multiple engineering degrees
from cu boulder. I'm just kidding.
Uh, but you know, from watching you on
the show, I mean, one would think, uh,
that you did and it's actually
amazing. I, I spoke to you for a seat.
Yeah. So it's been a lot of back
and forth getting ready to do that.
But that's what's made this show I think
so unique is that it's a scientifically
honest show.
It's a scientifically accurate portrayal
of what the future might look like
based on what's happening
right now, uh, in space, uh,
exploration. Uh, so what we do
is jump into the, uh, the clips.
The first, this is season one.
Tamara's will be risky, dangerous,
but it will be the grease
adventure ever,
ever in human history.
Funny thing about Mars,
it feels like birth.
It is more hostile to life.
Any place on earth,
in the absence of gravity, lots of
things can go wrong. It's an unknown.
And you're basically allowing
yourself to be an experiment.
Well coming in too fast, landing
hazard, four and a half, just firing it.
The question is,
will you be able to survive during this
crucial time of arrival losing him?
These people are putting their bodies
at risk for us, for the human race.
When we get to Mars, we need protection
from radiation, unmanned aerial vehicles.
We use a sense of drones to find a lover
Tube with the conditions we need to
deploy a small dam habitat and that
little foothold will become humankind's
first real home beyond the
gravity, well, Olympus town.
If I push this modification any farther,
we risk overloading the entire electrical
system. We don't have a choice.
What did you do?
If the topography is right in the isis
there we can justify the planet can, okay,
not scared of the dark.
Okay.
If there was water on Mars,
couldn't there possibly be lying?
Medical lab is now curation.
The greenhouse is complete.
We at MMC field that
we're ready to go faster.
Phase two expansion will be
overseen by the very best.
Our dream is now a reality.
You guys up for a welcoming
committee base commander and son,
and then two months we'll have enough
power to double the size and capacity of
your facilities.
It's a little too ambitious right now.
Young, go to march with that ambition.
I don't think we didn't get a
chance to get that reaction. Okay.
If you've got a dust storm that lasted
for a month, you'd be in big trouble.
This asking, ranging form
up. They call it a season.
I don't do my job. Who is going to have
a real problem is based. Ultimately,
there are some people who are going
to have a really hard time. Well,
I miss getting to everyone.
Are you missing home? I'm okay.
He lifts for his work and he can't do it.
Darling Paul Richardson
House
has to be buried. Our friends,
the fate of the mission
earth.
If you send astronauts
to Mars and they die,
their public opinion will prohibit
you from ever doing it again.
Took them to be strong, to make a
statement that says, we're here to stay.
Seven of the world's most beloved
scientists and astronauts are dead.
You're not going to have
someone's plan recommendation.
The committee when we thought
he could only get darker,
there was flight.
We have been talking about
life on Mars for ever.
That's like, I'm not gonna like crystal.
Have you had an iPhone? Something?
Just think about what it would mean if
you found a single cell micro organism
today marks the end of an era
and the beginning of a new one here
would be so exciting to wake up in the
morning and think that that's, that's
why it's happening. There is life on Mars
man or been coming to Maria
would be plans for his planet.
Scientists for Galt,
sick minus with the advancement
of Sciences. Hums industry.
When you look after your
water and your buyer, sorry,
I as such is becoming irrelevant on
your watch. Mars private enterprise.
Yes. It's uncomfortable. When we
talk about what we're doing on Mars,
we're really talking about what we
think is okay to do here on this planet.
What's your same drill baby drill?
I'm a Safa struck a deal with Luke from
industry hit the minus what they want.
Yes, they're doing a job, but they also
are creating wines for themselves. Okay,
ma'am, ma'am, I'm pregnant.
It's not like a plan. This. No,
you just plan to leave. If we go to
Mars, you don't want any surprises.
Does a baby is born on Mars? Could never
live here. Oh God got talking about.
We're ahead and technology and workers
will be pushed faster than they should be
pushed. Let me help them and those
errors have disastrous consequences.
We cause a sense they proved just
as challenging as it does on earth.
Do you see something?
Come on then what we're looking for,
we think we're going to let you and your
calling. You're one crazy bitch. You know
if there's a place you've never been,
there's a scientist wants to know what's
their companies want access to new
territory.
At the same time,
we have a counter movement that says
we are not going down without a fight.
Mazda's core though is willing to
accept a much higher level of of danger.
Solar flare.
It's taken out of electrical pride.
Our entire communications. She could
freeze to death before we find her.
We've disrupted the environment to
creating new conditions where diseases can
spread. What do we got? Something at
the site has been making them sick.
Stop the drilling.
When's governments are hiding an outbreak?
That's one of the virus is
actually, yeah, winning what?
You'd be walking straight into the sauce.
The only one who knows this science.
She's not breathing.
I need help.
It's my opinion that this
colony requires new leadership
colony just engaged and in this
town to the it or not get a chance.
People would lie, cheat, and steal to
make sure that the mission was successful.
Even if that costs a lot of human lives.
Take hold this
and I'll do mine.
They've taken advantage of us at
every turn and you let it happen.
Will we make mistakes on Mars?
Yes.
There's show for it.
You see something that has unimaginable
wealth and you want to go get it and
we're getting water today initiating
final prep before designation that comes
with an asterisk.
Space exploration.
It's where we solve problems that have
never been solved before for you. Okay?
With what he's doing.
Can you find life but not at the
expense of it. Nothing is a clean slate.
We impose ourselves on everything.
The future of humanity is
very much in the solar system.
What kind of civilizations
are we going to bill?
Ah, so what you saw there, uh,
was it just a brief recap of
season one, which was, you know,
all about the initial settlement. Uh, the,
the scientific undertaking that that
initial settlement was about a basic
survival in that settlement.
And then in season two, a,
the expansion, the
inevitable expansion, uh,
as industry comes in and,
uh,
some of the personal challenges and
conflicts that arise, uh, between,
you know, science objectives
and industry objectives, um,
many of which play out in
this world all the time, uh,
that we are portraying in
the future on Mars. Um,
and so with that, um, as kind of
background, we could start a Q and. A.
Um, and so, uh,
I actually have a question prepared
for each of the panelists. Uh,
but um, you are welcome to
ask questions as well. Um,
I might,
you know,
give you a little heads up that we're
going to be asking the audience for
questions in just a minute, but let
me start, uh, we'll just go this way.
Let me start with you, Steven. That's
okay. Um, that's all the questions
and we'll talk about terraforming later,
but let's start out just by talking
about what it's like for you personally,
uh,
to see this creation put together by this
wonderful team of actors and writers,
producers, uh, all
based on that, you know,
relatively small book that you wrote,
very important but small in size,
a book that you wrote.
Uh,
how's that,
how's that feel and how do you think the
portrayal has gone in terms of accuracy?
Good. Um, well, what's
the big shock? I've been,
I'm a science journalist
my whole life and, um,
and I've never been kind of buffered
up against the Hollywood syndrome.
So when we first got involved in this
project and the book was first optioned by
radical media,
um,
there were all kinds of twists
and turns that were kind of crazy.
I'm like getting space x
to cooperate with us. Um,
which was a very difficult
problem initially. Um,
and then seeing how this concept of
storytelling was far more important to
anyone in on the west coast than the
facts where to anyone on the east coast
where I was. So there was kind of
this thing going on between us and,
and my role quickly became not just
explaining as was Bobby's role,
uh, initially and in the show,
not just explaining to the film,
making people in the actors and so forth,
what the real facts were about being
on Mars and the kinds of scenarios you
could have. And you
couldn't have, for example,
I will never forget a phone
call from the director, um, uh,
in the first season.
And we were talking about,
I'm actually leaving earth and going to
Mars and the trip. And they said, okay,
somebody's got to die on this.
How are they going to die?
So I gave him like five scenarios from
my favorite scenario was that a small
meteoroid, um, would pass through
the rocket and they said, no,
we don't like that. And then I gave
him a couple of other scenarios.
Now we don't like that and a game a couple
of days, no, I don't like that. And uh,
it was like, well, wait a
minute, you know, um, what
kind of scenario do you want?
And they would give me one and I would
say that isn't physically possible in
space. So, um, initially
there was, there was,
there was a lot of, you
know, conflict of buffering.
I'm trying to come up trying to get the
people who wanted to do the storytelling
and we're very good at it,
um,
to adapt to the physical
realities of the universe.
But in the end it worked
out great. And, um,
one of the things that really surprised
me was that both the actors and the
directors, um, we're
really eager to learn.
Like when I first met the
initial group of actors,
every single one of
them had read the book.
Some of them had read the
book two or three times.
And the book served as kind of a primer
because it kind of laid out all the
facts of, you know, what
it would be like on Mars,
what it would be like getting
there, what are, you know,
it's very science based and very
fact based. And they really,
they really absorbed that
and wanted to learn that.
So it's been a lot of fun.
Um,
Anna and I've learned an awful lot,
you know,
I thought as a journalist and as a
writer and as an editor and you know,
I used to be a,
um,
kind of a writer's editor who worked with
really long form kind of stories that
you would,
the kind of stories you would see in the
New Yorker or the New York Times Sunday
magazine.
You know,
I thought I knew everything that I
was ever going to need to know about
storytelling and this new
dimension, which is visual, um,
taught me an awful lot and it taught
me an awful lot about scene setting and
words as well as sin in visuals
and carrying through a storyline.
So, um, I'm very grateful for the whole.
All right. Thank you.
Thanks a Antonio. Uh,
first of all, welcome back to boulder.
You're a hometown from here. Nice. Yeah.
Great. Yeah. Um,
you play a extremely important role in
season two as one of the big thinkers.
Uh, and, and in fact your
insights in the show, you know,
personally I have found
fascinating, um, you know,
the drilling on Mars,
drilling on earth and you know,
kind of parallels and
challenges. Uh, in that vein,
can you talk a little
bit more about how you,
how you view what we've,
what we're doing today presently
to the earth and on the earth,
how you view that playing out,
uh, in the future on Mars? Sure.
Yeah, it is great to be home.
I live in San Francisco now,
but I grew up in boulder,
so it's really great to be back
here and see the brand new campus.
And thanks for all of you for being here.
So as you saw on the previews,
what's really exciting,
one of the things that's really exciting
about the show is I do think this model
is entirely unique and, uh, just
revolutionary way of storytelling,
which is the hybrid of the documentary
and the drama. So they're interlaced,
as you saw it,
you've got the dramatic series in the
future on Mars and then you have the
documentary and you go back
and forth between the two.
And both sets become characters in a way.
Like you want to know, I think, what,
not only what's going to happen
to the characters in the drama,
but what the next big thinker is going
to say because you also become invested
in them. Cause they're
carried through the storyline,
the documentary storyline as well.
But in the first season,
the documentary is basically about,
you know,
the science of getting to
Mars in the second season.
The documentary is really about,
um,
what are the unforeseen consequences
that we've treated as unforeseen
consequences on earth.
That has led us to a devastation of our
ability to cohabitate with this planet.
And will we follow those same,
uh,
failures as we go to the next planet
and trying to learn those lessons.
And that's basically, you
know, from my perspective,
or at least my role in the
documentary and my role is about,
is looking at the failure of
resource extraction on earth.
And will the failure of resource
extraction on earth be carried forward.
And the failure of resource extraction
on earth is really well embodied in oil
extraction. And so that's sort of the
tool that's followed in season two.
As you saw,
green peace is followed as they go head
to head with oil drilling in the Arctic
with the outcome of oil drilling,
um,
in the small peninsula of the Russian
Arctic and in the drilling platform and
the Norwegian Arctic.
Um,
and you know,
I think what is really some of the
crux of the storyline and how I have
summarized the two seasons from my
own perspective is the first season is
looking at Willmar's kill the humans
that go there. And the second season is,
well,
the humans kill Mars.
And that is looking at what's,
what's going to happen when and if this,
um,
major industry comes and the depiction
of the industry in lucrum industries,
um,
is really incredibly spot on in the way
it's written in the portrayal of the
actors in the difficulties they face.
And the,
and the decision to, um,
you know, as, um, Jeff, uh,
who, who's the actor in the clip says,
you know, drill baby, drill quoting,
Sarah Pailin. Um, and,
and I think that the lessons are really
well embodied in both sets of stories.
Um, one of the critical issues that's
raised, you know, is there life on Mars,
one of the big challenges that happens
with oil drilling, um, what, what, what,
what one sees over and over and
over again with oil drilling.
The history of the last 150 years of
oil drilling is the drilling goes first.
And only afterwards that we then learn,
oh wait,
there was this really
critical natural resource. Uh,
there was this group of people
who lived here. Um, you know,
there were all sorts of consequences that
only get thought of as an afterthought.
And one of the best examples
of that in Arctic drilling,
which I think is a good parallel to what
could happen on Mars is something that
seems really inconsequential.
And that's phyto plankton.
It just looks like a seaweed,
but it turns out that phyto plankton,
if you destroy it, it provides 50% of
the oxygen we need to live on the planet.
So treating it as a sort
of inconsequential thing
is one of the reasons why
we're facing the problem
that we're facing right now.
And so trying to learn the lesson,
which is
maybe, um, consider
the consequences first,
longterm consequences first,
and just go, you know, go in,
uh, it go in second
with the, uh, you know,
blind pursuit of the,
of the resource. That's great. Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you. Uh, Leonard.
So, um, you know, great for you to
be here today, Leonard. Uh, so, uh,
you know, our interaction
dates back to actual, you know,
space flight missions,
right?
And I'm typically used to seeing
Leonard David articles written, uh,
about insight or about Mars 2020.
So I spelled his name right all the way
back to Mars Pathfinder in the nineties.
Right.
So I'm very interested in
your opinion of this show,
which is a portrayal of a future mission,
uh,
because I know that you've
very accurately covered, uh,
so many existing missions. Uh,
can you comment on that briefly?
Well, you know, I think one thing,
it strikes me the drill baby
drill thing before I forget,
that's also a Christmas k line.
He's a Mars scientist and he wants a
drill subsurface to look for life to look
for. So it's, um, and the
atmosphere is changing. I love that.
Um,
subtitle because this morning I
got up and I looked at insight.
We just landed on Mars few days ago.
Uh,
Cyrus racks pulls up at
an asteroid yesterday.
The Japanese space agency has a, uh,
another asteroid mission that's uh,
uh, also on, on target. Three
people left the earth the other day.
They hedge to the space station.
Um,
space x just hurled out,
you know,
60 some satellites out at one rocket
and then flew the, boosts your back.
And I think that's atmosphere changing.
I've never seen so much
activity in the last week,
uh, and in something something's going
on here, and it's not just the NASA,
but it's,
it's a global effort.
And when you think about what's
coming for Mars, we have, uh,
a Mars 20, 20, the NASA
super cute curiosity rover,
um, that'll take off. And the 20,
20 a China's going to launch
a Mars mission of robotic
mission, same time period.
Uh, the UAE,
they're going to be launching
a Mars orbiter. Um, uh,
it's absolutely incredible what's
happening. And Mars is, you know,
it's, it's dangerous. It's,
it's destiny. You know, for me,
I've always felt that Mars
was a, from a kid, uh,
covering early Mars missions, uh, Viking,
particularly in 1976.
That was just a thrill.
The first pictures come back
and of course you're looking,
you want to see rabbits running
around up there and whatever.
And I just remember the one guy,
I think it was a,
I can't remember his name now, but he,
there's rocks there have rocks on Mars.
Okay. Not quite rabbits, but
it was good enough for me.
But yeah, the whole, the, you know,
the future is now, I just, I, I really,
uh, honesty got last in
the last week and a half.
How many things have happened?
Unbelievable. Okay. That's true.
Um, I mean it's a, it's a whole new era
of space exploration right now. Yeah. Uh,
in the U S it's not only the
government, right? There's companies,
they're doing things on their
own. It's incredible. Um, so, um,
let's, let's see what kind of
questions you all have for us. Um,
anybody want to go first?
Okay.
Uh,
less of a technology question,
but I was just curious that where you
do the majority of your filming and how
much is CGI versus how much
is the actual physical sets?
There's a $15 million worth
of sets in Budapest right now.
They're all packaged up.
They were in a,
a container building,
um,
is typical of Hollywood sets that you
could have parked about seven and seven.
47,
10.
MMM.
Built the largest green screen ever in
the history of movie making so that we
could go to Morocco and
photograph where rovers,
Nasa Rovers who tested because
it actually looks like,
and it was a lot like the surface of Mars.
Then project that on the screen,
then have the actors in
front of that screen.
That's kind of remarkable
stuff that they've done.
They built full size sets
for the first season.
When I was walking through the sets,
I mean you,
you really can begin to think you're
on Mars and just a few minutes because
it's,
things are so realistic.
Down to there was a little container
in a hallway and the sets and the first
season on Mars and I picked it up and
looked at it and it was his container that
supposedly something had been brought
to Marson and it had like six different
labels on it, you know, approved by
inspectors such and such, uh, and,
and Houston and stuff like that.
I mean down to the level that the
camera would never pick up. Um,
the sets were so elaborate and so exacting
because it allows the actors to get
into role and really feel
like that there. So, um, we,
we unfortunately lost
our spot in Budapest.
Budapest has now become a very popular
place to make movies in many movies that
you think are British or American or
actually made in Budapest these days. And,
uh, we're probably gonna
move to Bucharest for the,
for the next season if there's
a next season. But, um,
because it's cheaper to make
films there, but, uh, the,
it's pretty elaborate stuff, you know,
it's the stuff of making real movies,
um,
as opposed to just a documentary series.
So the investment in this
has been extraordinary. I
think for the first season,
the sets where there were $5 million
worth of sets and for the second season
they had another $10 million from
the sets and they, the second season,
the sets are just huge compared
to the first season. So,
and I think if there's a third and a
fourth season, it will grow in that way.
Who Decides on that? How does, how
does that happen? Vice President said,
Fox
question in the middle there.
So we've been imagining Mars colonization
for years and years and years.
I'm thinking about today,
what things on challenges
had we anticipated before
and that we're now better
able to deal with?
And what new challenges have we discovered
that we didn't foresee back then?
That's probably for you. Well, I'll start,
but you can always add in a,
so I would,
I would argue that we've made great
progress in determining how to land big
things on Mars.
So a,
and this is an area that I've
worked in most of my career. Um,
and if you had asked me 10 years ago,
you know how we were gonna land humans
on Mars, I would have said know, I dunno.
Um, there were a lot of ideas out there
10 years ago or even 20 years ago.
There were a lot of kind
of cartoon drawings that
showed how one might do that,
but none of that technology
had been proven. Uh,
and recently I'm actually
here on the earth.
We've done a lot to prove
those technologies. So,
one example would be, um, you
know, when space ex, uh, returns,
the first stage boosters that they've
done successfully over 30 times,
now a way up high in the atmosphere,
when they're bringing that booster back,
they call out something called
an entry burn. And that burn, uh,
takes place supersonically in Mars
relevant conditions because you're up so
high,
you're up around 100,000 feet or higher
when that burned takes place and a,
what they're doing is they're,
they're firing their jets, uh,
in opposite to the direction of the
velocity. So opposing free stream,
uh, and that's something that actually
people have talked about a lot,
but until space x had a need to do that,
no one had ever done that in Mars
relevant conditions. And as I've said,
they've done it for a
big piece of hardware.
They've done it 30 times
or more successfully.
You don't see that because it happens so
high. You see the booster coming down,
you know, right on the drone
ship. And that's exciting too. Uh,
but for those of us that are
focused on Mars, we all work.
We care about what happened at 40
kilometers or so out to, to uh,
also at, through the robotic
program. I mean, you know,
I started my career by landing
Mars Pathfinder on the surface.
It landed a little rover called sojourner
that was about the size of a baby.
It weighed, it was 11 kilograms
in mass. And you know, uh,
Mars science laboratory is the
size of a small car, right?
It's a nuclear powered car
with a laser on it, right?
Then we landed in 2012 and
that, uh, by the way in 2020,
we're going to land much more accurately.
We're going to land basically
in a football field instead
of in a 20 kilometer
safe zone. So, um, you know, and that,
that kind of accuracy is required to
build up a base camp, right? If you,
in the series you see that
there've been many landings and,
and in order to build up this base camp,
those many landings have to happen in
close proximity to each other to get all
that hardware together. Uh, and that's
a technology that we're improving.
Uh, I think our ability
to keep people, you know,
alive frankly, and to keep them
safe so that they can live,
play and work in space.
Uh,
both in the micro gravity environment
of space and on another planet has been
greatly enhanced by what we're doing on
the international space station today.
A lender and mentioned the
three astronauts that just went,
but they joined three others that
are already there. And you know,
we've had people,
you know,
from our planet in space continuously
since 2001 think about that.
Not the same people,
but uh,
I mean that's a remarkable
achievement for our planet.
And it's not just Americans,
right?
They're international
astronauts included in that.
And to think that we've lived
off of our world continuously,
some smallest subset of us have done
so continuously and safely since 2001 a
that tells you something about
the reliability of the system.
The cruise systems needed to keep
people safe about food processing,
about water processing,
radiation shielding,
all of the kinds of technologies that
you see played out in this series.
They're happening today.
And then the last piece that I'll mention
and I'll see if you want to add to
that is,
is really correct.
It is just the advancement of
industry, frankly in this country. Uh,
it's one thing for our government,
uh,
to be talking about sending humans
back to the, it's great, you know,
exciting thing. Um, you know,
to repeat something like the
Apollo missions from the 1960s,
you know, it would be a fantastic
achievement for our country,
but what really impresses me and gets
me going gets my juices going is the
industry capabilities in this country
at places like space x or you know,
right here in Colorado at Lockheed
Martin, uh, or what's going on,
you know, with blue origin
or virgin galactic, uh,
all of these companies that are on their
own contributing to the space economy,
uh, planet labs that, you know,
is basically building almost a
real time Google earth. Right?
Um, I, you know,
it's remarkable what's happening in space
today and I think that capability is
required for us to efficiently
and cost effectively,
uh,
go to Mars.
I think from a tactical point of view
of one of the most interesting things
about going to Mars is that most of the
technology that you needed to do this
has been available for at least 30 years.
So I like to say 40 years,
but probably 30 years. Um, there's a,
there's a device on the new curiosity
rover that's going up in 2020 called Moxie
that we'll split the carbon atom off
this CO2 atmosphere of Mars and create
enough oxygen, um, for uh,
one human being to breathe consistently.
For example,
that machine is supposed to be scaled,
is designed to be scaled up
by a factor of a hundred.
I think NASA originally
wanted that machine so that
they could have an oxidizer
on Mars to make rocket fuel for
a return trip in the future.
But in fact,
that machine is probably going to turn
out to be the machine that makes the
oxygen that people need
to breathe on Mars.
I'm not quite sure what they're going to
use for the rest of them in their gas.
The other 78%,
that is still a technical problem.
But what's amazing is that all this stuff,
you know,
we made this decision to
stay in earth orbit a long,
long time ago.
It's the Apollo program was coming to
an end and we decided to build a space
shuttle,
which is supposed to be cheap and
reusable and it turned out to cost about
doubled over a billion
dollars for each flight.
And we have not kind of reached out and
extended what we're capable of doing.
We haven't gone back to the moon,
which I think would be kind of a waste,
but we haven't,
we haven't taken a bold step like we did
in the Apollo program and decided to,
let's just go to Maurice because we've,
and yet we've had this capability
to do this for so long.
And to touch on one other thing that
both Leonard and Bobby have touched on
spaces.
The next big business,
it isn't an accident that you see all
these things happening in, in the,
in the last week or so,
the Russians have committed to going
to Mars and putting a human on Omar.
The Chinese have to
putting a human on Mars.
Both the Russians and the Chinese have
committed to put humans on the moon again.
Uh, NASA has committed just recently
to putting humans on the moon again.
Um,
and yet as Bobby says,
there are all these private
companies that could actually do it.
Maybe even before any of these governments
could do it. Companies like space x,
which actually intend to do it
before a government does it.
This is the next big business,
you know,
lassoing the SLS launch system and the,
and the Orion capsule on that.
NASA has built,
one of the original things they wanted
to do with that literally was the go out
and find a near Earth asteroids and
Lasso it and bring it back and put it in
orbit around the moon so that commercial
companies could practice mining it.
That's real.
That's real technology that we have now
that we're capable of doing this is it's
just going to be mind blowing how this
stuff expands and it's expanding a lot
because of the commercial
aspects of space.
It's really going to be a big business.
Yeah. I mean, I think that's the perfect
place to chime in. I think that what's,
what is happening very rapidly is the,
is the movement towards securing
ownership of resources. What it,
who's going to own the resources.
And the only existing international
architecture was the um,
Moon Treaty, 67 space,
outer space, 1967 treaty.
And the goal was to not
have a militarized space.
That was the goal of that treaty.
It was a peace treaty.
Now it's being written our attempts,
there's already national legislation
that's happened in the United States and
other attempts that are being written to
define ownership of what you would mind
in space. Who owns it, who
gets to profit from it.
And that's all being driven right
now by private companies period. Um,
and that is a similar model,
which is will the private companies gain
ownership of asteroids and the rights
to mine asteroids and other planets and
what they get there and how they do it.
And we'll a regulatory regime only catch
up afterwards after it's happening.
And if that happens,
are the unintended consequences of mining
asteroids being thought through by the
people who are intending to do the mining
or will that be an afterthought? Um,
and so a cirrus rex, one
of its goals, this is the,
the mission,
um,
that Leonard just mentioned that
just yesterday successfully, um,
got the better it
doesn't, doesn't it? Yeah.
Got they're covering up.
I'm one of its goals is,
is to determine the viability of asteroid
mining. That's one of the intentions.
And so, you know, for someone like me
who has spent her career looking at,
you know, the sort of
follow, um, follow the,
the industry goes forward and sort of
regulations attempt to follow afterwards
and what the consequences of those are.
Thinking about it now for me,
this entirely new realm,
which is, you know,
all of space and what the
unintended consequences could
be is truly profound and
trying to encourage the public to
participate in this process as much as
industry is. Um, you know, before the
cat gets much further out of the bag
there, there was uh, some kind of line
and I don't think I came up with it.
I stole it from somebody probably, but
it was uh, it was the, you know, you,
you do the, the peaceful uses of
outer space and then somebody says,
uh, the useful, what,
how is this going now?
I can't remember what I'm
talking about. Okay. Yeah.
Useful pieces of outer space. Yeah. And
that's interesting. I have
a little quick, short story.
I used to go every time
there was a Mars mission,
I go to JPL had a time,
go talk to all the engineers and one
time I went in there and this was on
Pathfinder Guy, the head guy. He goes and
puts me in his office and
shuts the door and he says,
this fails, how will you guys
report on this? And I said, well,
how is this really gonna work?
He said, we're using the airbags.
Airbags. Okay, let's
see how that one goes.
That mission was the first time
I ever heard of co location,
which is what you folks do here.
And that was why it succeeded.
They had people co located in the
same buildings to talk to each other.
People that were working on the parachute,
um,
for a month would all sudden be
going over to another part of the,
the wheels of the rover.
And they,
each person learn more about their,
um,
spacecraft.
But that was called call location.
And then I went back a couple
years ago for curiosity. Landed,
how are you going to land
that? Oh, I'm a sky crane.
It'll be dropped down on
a tether and you're going,
I'm still buying drinks
on that one because I
all right, I can't. And that to me,
you know,
that,
uh,
the partnership that has to develop
between people in these missions to make
things happen is baton passing a space,
age baton passing.
And each person contributes to the whole.
And it's pretty amazing to watch
true
what work needs to be done before
we can actually send humans to Mars.
Hmm. Not much of anything.
Um, it's a problem of money.
Um,
mosque estimates that it's 36 below 35,
$36 billion to land the
first humans on Mars.
He doesn't have $36 billion.
If he did,
I think he'd probably start launching
cargo missions does a year. You need,
you need about three cargo missions
to land successfully on Mars.
Bobby and a lot of people from NASA think
the first cargo landing that space x
attempts on Mars will probably fail. And
uh, and they think that they will learn.
Huh?
Not probably a lot of,
a lot of people that I've talked to,
NASA seem to think it will
probably fail in my opinion.
I'm going to jump in.
All right. All right.
So what I've said is that if you need
three, you should send for, right. Just,
you know, before you send
the humans, cause one of them
may, may, yeah, go ahead.
But anyway,
there's a lot
to be learned from those failures.
Extraordinary.
I mean you probably learn if you have
a successful landing and part of it is
luck.
That's not a learning experience.
If you have a failure and you learn a
lot from the failure and then you don't
make the same mistakes again, um,
things work a lot better in the future.
So what I suspect is going
to happen is that, um,
as soon if Tesla,
it becomes as successful as it should be.
If mosque is able to
launch 7,000 communication
satellites and offer you data
and voice for nine 95 a month and
capture their 10 billion wifi connected
devices on the planet more
than there are people.
If he got to fourth of that Earth, a
fifth of that population, 2 billion,
and he gets $10 a month from everybody,
he's going to quickly have the
money to launch people to Mars.
So this is really a money problem and
not a technology problem. If justice,
we threw money at Apollo in the 60s,
4% of the GDP of the United
States went into that program.
Now about one 16th of the GDP of the
United States goes into an asset.
If you were to throw those kinds of
resources into landing people on Mars,
there would definitely be
people on Mars within 10 years.
So Elon Musk,
is he Cindy set that space x will land
people on Mars in the next six years.
What are your thoughts on that
timeline as a sub question? What is,
what do you think is a more realistic
timeline for that to happen? Right.
I think they're the kind of different,
when I originally wrote my book,
I must owe me 20, 24, 2025.
And I said, come on up.
And he said, he said, look, if we
haven't landed people on Mars by 2030,
I will be the disappointed.
And he met deeply disappointed,
that kind of failure that
he doesn't accept. Um,
he recently walked back his statement on
when the first humans would be on Mars.
He recently said, I don't think
many people notice this, but he's,
he was asked in an interview, um,
when the first people land on Mars,
and he said the thing he's been saying
recently, which is 2024 and then he said,
well at least I'm certain we'll
have a cargo missions by 2024.
And that was a real walk
back because he said,
I'm not sure we'll have people on Mars
in 2024 which is what he's been saying.
So, but I'm sure we'll have a cargo
mission. So give it a couple of years.
Maybe the first cargo mission is 26.
Next car
group mission is 2028 then 2030,
you have a cargo mission and maybe it's
simultaneously have you have two rockets
going into it and you'll
have a crew land that would,
that would be the estimate that
I would give you right now.
There's a catch 22 in all of this. Um,
and that's, it is the life on Mars.
Question is it,
there's going to be probably some new
information about methane detection on
Mars.
That's going to be a very interesting
possible connection for biology.
Uh, the other thing is happening and
there's a lot of concern about planetary
protection and the
coordination of, uh, uh,
of international groups and
Alon tossed his TESL out there.
And that was not a happy moment for
the planetary protection people. Um,
although, you know, didn't get near
and Mars or it's on some, you know,
flew past it. But, uh,
there's a problem and, uh,
there's a real,
I think there's going to be a headline
battle between a planetary protection
people and life detection people
and privatization of Mars.
So I'd watch that one that's
going to come and uh, we'll see.
Um, I, I, but I, and the
lawyer's thing is the greatest.
It's a head on collision. It's
just going to be wild. I mean,
it's the wild west sort of thing, but, um,
I think that's going to be another one.
I,
I've just finished writing up and I had
to go talk to a lot of lawyers and a,
they're there, you can have the
Rolodex of, you know, pro con, no,
we shouldn't do this and that.
So we got some real issues coming.
I mean,
I think the other issue that it is being
addressed in two separate questions
instead of one is this issue of where
the outer space treaty was a peace treaty
was the intention of it was a peace
treaty and how significantly more advanced
at this point weaponization of space and
money when you're talking about money,
the u s um,
defense space budget.
So the defense that the space
budget of the defense industry,
not NASA was $45 billion the last time
it was identified and that was in 2015.
So there's a lot of money there.
And then where and how is the overlap
being being discussed of as you move much
more quickly towards Mars and the amount
of money that's needed to do that and
where the money currently resides,
which is in the defense
industry and weaponization,
will there be a marriage that many people
who have for a long time sought piece
in space, uh, you know,
have fought to, to prevent,
that's what we need to
space for us anyway.
That's why we [inaudible] before
you jump on that one second,
I just add that,
um,
you know,
when you tried to
find a timeline for when will
the first humans will be on Mars,
it depends a great deal on what
the strategy is for those humans.
So it actually wouldn't be that hard to
just send a couple of humans to Mars,
have them be there for a few
weeks, you know, Allah Apollo,
and then have them come back. And we could
certainly as a country if we chose to,
we could do that in the
2020s, uh, but yeah,
but we would probably do an Apollo eight
kind of thing and we go into orbit and
come back and not actually land.
Well, we could do both. Yep.
But in the series, but in the
series, what we've chosen to do,
if you notice it's many of the same
astronauts from season one are still there
in season two, Sammy, uh, as an example.
And so if you're thinking about the
first humans going to settle Mars,
which is the way space x and
Elan Musk talk about this, uh,
there are many more cargo ships.
There's much more of a base camp
environment that needs to be built up,
a lot more infrastructure.
And so in my view,
you're talking about the 2030s,
by the time you would send those
humans because of all the, uh,
in placement of infrastructure
that has to go first.
W One, one good thing was, you know,
when I got the word to do this Mars book,
I was at a conference at Johnson Space
Center and they brought in all these,
uh,
scientist and for the first time in one
room people sat around and talked about
where do we, where do you land,
where do we land, and where,
where can this base fee? And then the
exploration zones were being drawn out.
I mean,
it's been real discussion of moving ahead.
There's a question back here,
so I apologize if feel fed
up with this question. Um,
were you influenced at all by Andy?
Where's but the Martian in the series?
And then vice versa.
Do you think he was influenced by your
work and what did you think of the
science?
I have a personal story about that,
which is,
so in my book came out in 2015
in July of 2015 in April of 2015,
um,
I had been asked to do a Ted
talk on bars and I did this talk,
I've done two other ted talks on the
main stage at Ted and they were both
greeted by wild applause and
people standing up and everything.
And this one one was treated but polite
applause. And I walked off the stage.
What the hell happened here?
Jeff Bezos had a dinner that night in
which he basically tried to criticize
every single thing I had said
about people going to Maurice.
And now this was a PR campaign by Elon
Musk to gain more attention for Tesla and
so forth.
And the people that ran ted,
who the guy who runs that is
a close friend of mine, said,
we're not putting your talk up online.
And then in September
the Martian came out.
So my book came out,
wasn't selling the Martian came out.
Um,
I had sat down with Charlie bolden when
I was writing the book and talked about
NASA's plans for humans landing on Mars.
And he took me to one of the 10,000 pages,
obscure pages of NASA that said in big
bold type NASA has no plans for human
mission to Mars. Right there
on the, on the website.
Marchionne comes out. All of a sudden
my book starts selling like crazy.
Ted Decides to put my talk up online.
Charlie bolden appoints a director of man
mission to Mars. Didn't have any staff,
but um,
so that's how much influence a
Hollywood movie had on society.
It right. It actually convinced
people that this was a possibility.
If Matt Damon can do it,
we can
nope.
Dance remix of Steven giving.
Yeah.
And I'll also point out,
yeah.
Did Andy, uh, participated as one of
the big thinkers? Yes. In season one.
So he was part of the first
season of the nat geo a series.
And, and I should mention that he's
gone through kind of a metamorphosis to,
he was very defensive initially about
the facts that were inaccurate in his
book. Like, you know, 300 mile an hour
wind on Mars is not going to drive a,
a piece of an antenna through your
space suit kind of thing. In fact,
you could walk through a 300
mile an hour wind on Mars easily.
It'd be like a three mile an hour wind on,
on earth.
And he was very defensive about that.
And then he got involved
in season one and you know,
some of us were kind of beating up
on him about that kind of stuff.
And then season two came around and we
beat up on him some more and now he's
very open about what was wrong.
He's a great guy. He's a great
guy. Yeah. All right. So, uh,
I'm told that we're at
a time, um, but I do,
I want to thank you all for
joining us here today. Uh, I'd,
I'd highly encourage you
to check out the series.
A season two is continuing.
You can check out episode five next
Monday at 9:00 PM on the nat Geo Channel.
Uh, and I want to also, uh, in
addition to thanking our panelists,
I want to thank Google for welcoming us.
Thank you very much.